تعتبر الولايات المتحده ان اوكرانيا بحاجه
ماسه الى مساعده عسكريا خصوصا الدفاعات
الجويه وتؤكد اداره الرئيس الحالي
انها ستستمر في تقديم هذه المساعده الرئيس
يوم الثلاثاء للتاكيد على ان لدى
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين خططا للتشريع
خلال الاسابيع المقبله
والحرب في اوكرانيا وكل المسائل الخلافيه
والمهمه وسنجد ارضيه المشتركه وهذا املي
لان الامريكيين يريدوننا ان نعمل معا هناك
خلافات بين الرئيس الديمقراطي وزعماء
الكونجرس الجمهوريين حول قضايا داخليه
كثيره وسيكون التوفيق بين الزعماء
الحاليين امرا ضروريا لكن موضوع المساعدات
لاوكرانيا يبدو مؤثرا نظرا لابعاده الضخمه
دوليه
تعمل في القرن لكن الاوكرانيين لا
يستطيعون اسقاطعه الا اذا امتلكوا مضادات
بعيده المدى المدارس
يبدو من كلام الزعماء الجمهوريين انهم
يطالبون الاداره الديمقراطيه بالمزيد من
المساعدات لاوكرانيا لكنهم يريدون ممارستا
رقابه اكثر على الاداره الحاليه
لكن من المؤكد ان الجمهوريين يريدون
المزيد في الشان الخارجي
في الغالب العربيه واشنطن